this video is brought to you by brilliant get a
free trial with brilliant and take advantage of
its hands-on stem learning
lessons more on them in a bit
in the twilight of imperial rule a woman rose
to power in china who would transform the middle
kingdom yanara singh better known as dowager
empress was as clever as she was ambitious
born into a respectable dish family she became
a low-ranking concubine in the forbidden city
only to work her way up to the very top
through a combination of intrigue cunning
and constantly underrated intelligence she rose
through a male-dominated world to become the
most powerful person in china and should use that
power to transform the empire as a woman behind
the throne seiji unleashed a wave of modernization
that upended the late qing dynasty under a 40-year
reign china opened up itself to the west began
to industrialize and even made moves towards
democracy yet for all the undoubted good she did
there was also a dark side to the dowager empress
implicated in a number of assassinations swept up
in the bloody horrors of the boxer rebellion sichi
walked a fine line between enlightened leader
and cold-blooded machiavellian today biographies
is investigating the story of the ordinary
girl who became imperial china's matriarch
there's no curse attributed to ancient china which
supposedly goes may you live in interesting times
none could have known it at the moment of a birth
but the girl who would become sichi was destined
to live through some of the most interesting times
in history born yahenara singh on november 29 1835
sichu's early life is shrouded in mystery almost
no formal records of her first 16 years exist
leaving us to piece together what we can from
later sources we know that she was a manchu part
of the minority ethnic class that had ruled
majority han china since the 1660s we know
too that her father was a mid-level government
official the sort of guy who could give his family
a comfortable life in a nice part of beijing
we also know that she was born at a point when
china was about to embark on an unprecedented
era of crisis in 1839 when sichi was just four
the first opium war would see china trounced
by the british beginning a multi-decade series
of conflicts civil wars rebellions and outside
interference known as the century of humiliation
but while the first opium war passed little tsuchi
bai she would soon find herself at the epicenter
of the wave of coming conflicts and speaking of si
chi now might be a good time to make a quick note
on names si chi was the name given to the girl
born yahanara singh once she reached the position
of dowager empress sort of like how in ancient
rome octavian became emperor augustus but since
sichi received a new name almost every time
she changed ranks there's just no way that
we're going to be able to use the chronologically
correct ones without confusing the hell out of
absolutely everybody so in the interest of making
things simple we're just going to call her cichi
throughout also regarding the pronunciation of her
name i did look it up there are some conflicting
ones but i went with my main pronunciation
dictionary which says cg so here we are everybody
as a girl in qing dynasty china tsuchi grew up
learning ladylike pursuits which meant that she
could paint and play chess but was never taught to
read or ride yet even at this young age there were
signs she wouldn't be bound by traditional
gender roles when sichi was a pre-teen the
dao guang emperor announced that serious money
was missing from the imperial treasury rather
than try and find the culprit he ordered anyone
who'd ever worked there to shoulder part of the
debt a description that unfortunately included one
of cicci's ancestors with the debt passed on to
living relatives her father was in danger of being
thrown in prison according to legend though sichi
went out and somehow managed to raise 60 percent
of the debt in loans from that point on the story
goes her father valued her opinion as highly
as he would a son kind of a backhand compliment
today but a serious deal in a society that ranked
women equal to well a comfortable armchair not
that sichi suffered as badly as most women of her
era as a manchu she was exempt from the painful
hand traditional foot binding a practice she had
banned in later life but while sichi's ethnicity
would save her feet from being mutilated the same
can't be said of a soul in 1850 the old emperor
died and was replaced with the shia feng emperor
this began imperial china one of the new emperor's
most important tasks was modernizing his empire
anything silly like that but rather choosing his
new harem so when she turned 16 si chi like every
manchu girl was summoned to the capital to partake
in an absurd face-to-face version of hot or not
in a courtyard of the forbidden city she was made
to stand with hundreds of other women while
xiafeng strutted up and down trying to decide
who to get jiggy with in the end it was her eyes
that did it every account ever written of cici
notes how enthralling her eyes were evidently
the emperor thought so too that day si chi was
one of 10 women chosen for xi'an feng's harem she
moved into the forbidden city on june 26 1852 as a
low-ranking concubine yet before a decade was out
she'd have managed to claw her way to the very top
for a teenage girl used to if we believe
the legends being treated as equal as a boy
life in the forbidden city must have been
unbearably strange to cj on the one hand she was
given maids and eunuchs to attend to her and she'd
lived with the other concubines in a grand set of
sweets on the other hand the men in her life had
gone from seeing her as almost as good as a boy
to a pretty sex robot that was only good for
one thing once while she was with the emperor
sichi made the mistake of trying to use her giant
brain to suggest ways the army might overcome the
deadly typing rebellion roiling china's south but
rather than being all like whoa this chick is uh
pretty smart shifeng was like a girl given a man
advice please gods in some tellings the emperor
was so angry he signed sichi's death warrant which
means the fact that this video isn't about to end
right now was down to one person on the same
day that sichi's eyes had caught the emperor's
attention another concubine had been admitted to
the palace called zhen but known to history asean
she'd been elevated to the rank of empress rather
than a source of jealousy between the two women
their different statuses would save cg's life
when she found out about the death warrant cian
went to the emperor and laid it on sick exactly
what she said is unknown but it likely involved
a whole lot of flattery and also the suggestion
that maybe just maybe an intelligent outspoken
concubine might be more useful alive than dead
whatever she said it clearly worked not only did
the emperor forgive sichi he promoted her boosting
her from his sixth rank concubine to number five
again to our ears that probably sounds like a
bit of a veiled insult but in imperial china
where rank was everything it represented a massive
boost in her fortunes she even got a new name from
her original concubine name of lan or orchid she
became ye exemplary but this would have nothing
on the boost she'd received soon after like many
global dynasties of the era the qing were obsessed
with producing male heirs unfortunately xi'an feng
was struggling like hell to sire any boys so when
cg gave birth to a child on april 27th 1856 and
it turned out to be a little dude with a pee pee
for the ching it was party time the birth of baby
zaichan when cigi was just 20 years old catbolled
at her from only alive thanks to cyan to second
most important woman in the country while chinese
custom and empress sian was legally considered the
mother being the concubine who burst the air still
carried a whole ton of cloud sichi was promoted
first to rank four then with no more concubines
producing male layers right up to rank three noble
consort it was the beginning of her rise to power
one that would only accelerate when her biological
son became the emperor and it turned out that was
going to happen a whole lot sooner than anybody
anticipated the same year zion was born the
british launched their wholly unwanted sequel to
the original opium war like any good blockbuster
the second opium war was bigger crazier and above
all else a cynical attempt to make its creators
as much money as humanly possible as the
typing rebellion continued to pull china
apart the british sent diplomats to negotiate
a brutally one-sided piece in retaliation the
emperor had them all arrested so the british
did what they did best they burned down one of
the seats of government the 1860 attack on the
summer palace came just as people gathered to
celebrate the emperor's 30th birthday sichi cyan
and more were forced to flee ahead of an orgy of
looting and burning in the wake of the palace's
destruction what other choice did the emperor have
broken crushed jianfeng dispatched his brother
prince gong to make peace the resulting treaty
saw china humiliated swathes of territory were
lost europeans were given staggering concessions
in trade and religious freedom and exemptions
from chinese laws for an emperor who'd grown up
despising the west it must have been a bit of
a bitter pill to swallow fortunately jianfeng
wouldn't be around to witness the aftermath in
august 1861 the emperor began coughing up blood
after a short illness he passed away leaving only
a single male heir and just like that young cg
found herself mother of the new emperor now just
before we continue with today's video let me tell
you about today's fantastic sponsor brilliant
brilliant for those who don't already know
is a website and app built on the idea of active
problem solving because it takes more to learn
something than just watching it to really learn
something you actually have to do it you have
to practice it which is why brilliant has tons of
lessons on its platform for lifelong learners who
aren't just content to coast through adulthood
with the skills that they learned in school for
example have you ever wanted to learn how computer
programming works but were put off by intimidating
an opaque coding language well brilliant help
you learn how to program without having to dig
deep through the weeds of coding syntax this is
thanks to fun interactive challenges brilliant
users can shift around blocks of pseudo code
that then get immediate feedback on their
results it's an engaging way to understand how
computer algorithms work and once you've got
that down the coding syntax becomes just a lot
less intimidating on brilliant it's not about
memorizing or regurgitating facts for a test
you can just pick a course you're interested
in and get started feeling stuck afraid you made a
mistake it's never an issue with brilliant you can
just read the explanation to find out more and
learn at your own pace so if you're a lifelong
learner who wants to give brilliant a try you
guys can get a free trial plus 20 off the cost of
a year subscription by following the link in the
description below and now back to today's video
uh of course this being the chinese imperial court
things weren't quite as simple as little zai chan
putting on a crown and sigi suddenly becoming boss
of the palace on his deathbed jianfeng signed a
proclamation placing power in the hands of eight
men under his advisor sushem the idea was that
these men would act as regents until the boy came
of age but since seshun was clearly plotting to
take control for himself tsichi asked the emperor
directly who would succeed him when xianfeng
replied with uh my son obs well the stage was set
for an epic power struggle so here's the situation
as we go into battle on one side we have the
powerful advisor sushun and his cabal of prominent
men all favored both politically and by their
gender on the other hand we have the recently
elevated dowager empress tsuchi and sian with a
bit of secret help from xianfeng's brother prince
gong the goal to become official decision maker
for the zai chun the new tongzi emperor the prize
well make yourself the most powerful person in all
of china and in a real-life squad game like this
there could only be one winner at the moment the
starting gun was fired on this epic show done
smart money was on a social victory after all he
was important connected a respected powerful male
going up against a former concubine you
can almost imagine him cackling like
dick dastardly as he declares don't worry little
lady this will hurt you more than it hurts me but
in this our villain would be proven spectacularly
wrong for all society may have regarded her as
a mere concubine there was nothing mere about
cg she was shrewd intelligent and don't forget
versed in chess from a young age and in the giant
three-dimensional chess game that sushen didn't
even know he was playing she could see a bazillion
moves ahead the first smart thing cc and cian did
was getting everyone to agree to let them write
the royal seal in this era all chinese laws had
to be literally signed off by the emperor but
since xiaochung was so young having the whole
nation weight on a five-year-old's handwriting
skills was a clear route to disaster so si chi was
all like yeah you know what how about me and sian
do it and just save everybody the trouble yeah to
which sushen ascended probably while smirking
about how it fobbed her off with trinkets but
the power to make laws actually legal obviously
wasn't a trinket at all still cicci couldn't just
write a letter saying feeds are shown to the lions
and sign it into law no no no she needed a reason
to take down her nemesis which leads us up to
her second smart move making a child cry one day
when sushen and the regents were doing their thing
tsuji came up to them with zeitung in tow she was
then just so objectionable the regents lost their
tempers and started shouting at her which caused
zychum to burst into tears rather than whoops
sorry my bad sichi instead declared that the
regents had disrespected the young emperor and act
tantamount to treason it was around this time that
sushen began plotting to kill her but his plans
were too little too late in november 1861 a 10-day
funeral procession was held for the dead gianfeng
informs hashem that she'd only be available for
part of the ceremony but that he should attend the
whole thing since it'd be a show of great respect
perhaps spooked by the whole bowling emperor
episode sushen agreed then while he was out at
the funeral si set up the perfect checkmate during
the ten days sichi cyan and prince gong worked
feverishly to whip up palace sentiment against the
regions finally at the end of the procession they
unveiled a proclamation in zeitung's name signed
by c.g seal and it charged them all with treason
sasham was arrested and sentenced to death by a
thousand cuts a sentence chi commuted to death
by decapitation two other regions were ordered to
commit suicide and the rest were stripped of their
wealth and sent into exile in the wake of the
near bloodless coup a second proclamation went
out this one declaring that cyan and sichi with
advice from prince gong would now decide on all
matters of state and with that it was game set a
match aged just 26 cichi had done it along with
cyan she had outmaneuvered everyone to become the
most important person in china and what's a sharp
ambitious girl to do with near unlimited
power why transform her country of course
from the moment session was executed sichi
became effectively the ruler of china a position
that should hold all the way through to 1908.
yet thanks to agenda that position would never
be official she would be treated as equal to the
emperors she ruled on behalf of forced to sit
behind a silk screen during meetings and forbidden
from setting foot in front of the imperial palace
despite these limitations though she'd wind up
overseeing one of the most transformative programs
in chinese history with prince gong focused on
practical matters and sian happy to stay in the
shadows it would be sichi who'd make the major
policy decisions perhaps one of the most major
was to pivot china towards the west although the
opium wars were over now the taiping was still
causing chaos so sichi put aside the humiliation
of the unequal treaty signed with britain france
and others and instead asked them for help
modernizing her army the british agreed and did
such a good job that the ching were finally able
to end the taiping rebellion in 1864 by which time
some 20 million people had died but this
massive military upgrade would turn out
to be only the beginning of china's westward
tills under the self-strengthening movement
trade was further opened up to europe western
schools were established to teach european
languages western officials hired to clamp
down on corruption and graft advisors were
invited from the leading economies to do
everything from spearhead agricultural reforms to
teach the ching military how to build modern
weapons the result was a slow but steady opening
up a transformation that saw china gain its first
modern navy postal service and monetary system the
first vestiges of industrialization crept in two
as mines were opened and telegraph systems were
laid not that sichi's embrace of western style
modernity was absolute no matter how hard outside
investors tried they couldn't get china to invest
in railroads tsuchi was just too adamant that the
noise would disturb ancestral tombs dodged across
the countryside it would take until 1876 for her
to get permission for a single working line to
be laid by which time the political conditions
would have drastically changed first there
was the accidental near war with france that
came close to crisis with china becoming
stronger plenty of sichi's advisers such as
prince gong's brother prince chun were demanding
that she used that new strength to get revenge
for the unequal treaties when cigi demurred chun
helped orchestrate anti-christian riots riots that
saw french citizens lynched luckily the disaster
of the franco-prussian war meant that france was
less willing to fight than usual and tsuchi
managed to mollify paris but the second
shake-up would be even bigger on january the
2nd 1875 zytrum died of smallpox not yet 20.
although he'd taken over as emperor when he was
16 zychum still hadn't managed to sire in air
while his empress was pregnant when he died her
family ordered her to starve herself to death in
a show of piety although rumors persist that cg
arranged the whole thing with no sun to elevate
the dying emperor handed the power to choose his
successor to sichi the successor she chose prince
chun's three-year-old son now there are a couple
of different ways to read this the first cynical
one is that xichi and sian weren't interested
in stepping aside and needed a new very young
emperor that they could rule in place of since
his son becoming emperor would also force the
annoying prince chun to give up his duties that
was two birds with one stone the slightly kinder
reading is that the dowager empress was hamstrung
by convention unable to pick anyone older than
the dead emperor had been and lacking any decent
teenage candidates either way chun's infant was
elevated to guangzhou emperor and sian and sichi
officially made his parents while the boy was told
to address sian as his mother he was made to refer
to sichi as blessed father simple expediency or cg
signaling loud and clear that she was as good as
any male well we'll let you be the judge as the
1870s closed then tsuchi was firmly ensconced
at the head of a powerful triumvirate leading a
rapidly modernizing nation into the last years
of the 19th century yet comfortable as she was
she couldn't shield herself from all misfortunes
and the dawning of the new decade was going to
bring with it something the dowager empress had
never experienced before real unimaginable tragedy
generally speaking popular sentiment has
seen sichi in one of two ways the first
is the more modern view as a strong capable
woman who created a brief oasis of stability
in a century of chaos the other is as the chinese
equivalent of agropina a murderous she-devil who
murdered everybody who got in her way which minion
you subscribe to will probably dictate how you
feel about what happens next on april the 8th
1881 succee's co-region xian suddenly died aged
just 43. for those of the cg murdered everyone's
school of chinese history this is evidence that
her lust for power was growing causing her to
bump off her only rival but for those who prefer
shade more nuance a kinder reading is that this
was the first time tsuji was forced to face real
tragedy from the moment shid intervened with xi'an
feng to save the older woman's life cyan had been
suchi's one constant ally her friend a confident
a protector to suddenly be without her must have
been like waking up one day to find your legs
have vanished a shock you can't ever imagine
recovering from certainly sian's exit seems to
have destabilized the dowager empress the ears
that followed saw the reforming zeal of the 1870s
give way to a kind of directionlessness as sichi
refused further industrialization and got in a
short inconclusive war with france of vietnam and
even ended up firing her loyal lieutenant prince
gong finally in 1889 it seemed as if had enough
as the guangzhou emperor reached maturity the 54
year old cece announced that she was stepping down
there'd be no new child emperor no attempt to
cling to power just a peaceful retirement to
an expensive recreation of the summer palace to
wait out the end of her days at least that was
the plan as can be seen throughout human history
though once someone has been in power too long
it can be hard for them to let go especially if
their successor isn't up to scratch and guangzhou
was all too aware of his weaknesses even once made
emperor prince chun's son would meet sichi several
times a week to seek her advice a habit but soon
led his own advisors to basically say screw it
why don't we just get this and just go and talk
directly to see jim now this arrangement wasn't
necessarily fatal not if gwangju and sichi were
pulling in the same direction but what if there
was some say gigantic catastrophe that pushed
them in opposite directions well in 1894 that
catastrophe blew up in the shape of the first
sino-japanese war we'll likely cover this over on
our new channel wara graphics one day go over
and subscribe to that so we'll keep things rather
simple here and the simplest version is that china
got its arse absolutely whipped in the aftermath
of this latest humiliation guangxi became
convinced that si chi's reforms hadn't gone far
enough that china needed to modernize now to stand
any chance of catching up with its belligerent
neighbor so against sichi's wishes the emperor
launched 100 days reform in 1898 determined to
upend society instead he brought about his own
downfall always against these reforms si chi was
told by our advisors that guangzhou had become
a puppet of japan so with a coldness matched
only by her competence she launched a coup the
emperor was arrested imprisoned on an island his
fellow reformers were executed or else they
fled to tokyo by the time the dust settled
the reform era was definitively over once again
china's matriarch was in charge this time though
it would be the aging dowager impress herself
who'd wind up unleashing chaos on her people
one reason people have so differing opinions on
cg is that there are few instances where things
are totally clear-cut like maybe she killed
her rivals or maybe she didn't maybe she was
foolish to end the guangzhou emperor's reforms
but maybe her own reformist history gives her a
pass however there's no ambiguity where the box
rebellion is concerned no matter how you cut it
sichi's response to the uprising was a disaster
launched in 1899 by the epically named righteous
and harmonious fists the boxer rebellion was an
anti-western anti-christian insurrection that
ultimately killed a hundred thousand people in
the early stages these deaths were westerners and
chinese accused of picking up western habits but
then the eight nation alliance of austria-hungary
the usa great britain france italy germany japan
and russia they launched a joint invasion of china
to protect their citizens and everything went
absolutely nuts rather than suppress the boxes
tsuchi came out on their side declaring a war
for survival against the eight nation alliance
this led to the alliance attacking beijing where
the boxers were laying siege to foreign embassies
causing sichi and a court to flee it was like the
burning of the summer palace all over again but
while the british had very much been at fault
in 1860 in 1900 sushi had to shoulder at least
some of the blame the boxer rebellion ended in
1901 with an alliance victory and mass execution
of suspected rebels the treaty then forced
on china was so humiliating it made even the
ending to the second opium war looked like mere
fetish play in comparison crippled by a gigantic
indemnity beijing was pushed toward bankruptcy
foreign troops were stationed in the nation on a
permanent basis but one aspect of pre-rebellion
life that would survive was tsiti herself in
1901 tsuji issued the decree of self-reproach
blaming herself for the war she then tried to
make amends by ushering in something called the
late-ching reforms an overhaul of the state that
went beyond even what the emperor had attempted
tax policing the judiciary education were all
completely upended foot binding was banned
into ethnic marriages between bahana manchus
legalized a degree of press freedom instituted
by 1906 cichi was even decreeing that china would
become a constitutional monarchy complete with
elections and degree of male suffrage potentially
the greatest reform the nation had yet seen but
in the end it wouldn't be sichi's late life edicts
that had the greatest impact on history but what
she did on her final day in 1908 sichi fell badly
ill tensing that the end was near it seems she
acted to preserve her legacy on november the
14th the guangzhou emperor died in his luxurious
prison a hundred days later scientific analysis of
his body would confirm that he was poisoned with
arsenic did sichi bump him off we can't say for
sure maybe it was a wider conspiracy in which her
own illness was also the result of poisoning but
if any of the deaths in this video could be laid
at her feet it's probably this one surely after
the airless emperor's death sichi chose the man
who would succeed him or rather the boy prince
chun's two-year-old son poiyi famous today as the
last emperor mere hours later sushi herself died
on november 15 1908 she was 72. at the moment she
passed suchi was the grand matriarch of an empire
that had lasted in various forms for thousands
of years an empire that was in need of reform
certainly but making steps in the right direction
within three years though all of that would have
been swept away in 1911 puyi would be deposed in
a revolution leading china to collapse into the
anarchy of the warlord era a process that would
eventually lead to the rise of two competing
visions for the future that of chiang kai-shek and
that of mao zedong but by then cg would have been
lost to history a tomb destroyed in 1927 a body
desecrated and then thrown away like so much trash
in the decades since the daughter empress's
reputation has been on a wild ride from a figure
of revulsion she came to be seen as a complex
failure and more recently as a strong admirable
woman who did her best to lead her country through
a dark time today we're finally in a position to
appreciate the nuances of her rule to see clearly
both the good and the bad without a doubt she was
a remarkable figure a woman who rose to power in a
man's world and then proceeded to reform imperial
china in ways no man had ever dreamed yet we
also have to accept that those reforms ultimately
failed that she stopped the last necessary steps
under the guangzhou emperor then left behind a
system that wouldn't survive another half decade
was she brilliant venal inspirational destructive
the truth is that she was maybe all these things
and many more a woman who shaped the destiny of a
billion people in some areas brilliantly in others
such as the boxer rebellion catastrophically
what she never was though was inconsequential
for both good and ill sichi shaped china for
nearly half a century and that alone ensures that
she'll never be forgotten so i really hope you
found today's video interesting if you did please
do hit that thumbs up button below don't forget to
subscribe also as i mentioned wara graphics
new channel link below thanks for watching
you